the lush landscape of georgia's rioni
valley
is being re-engineered for the
hydropower plant of
namakhvani when completed
two dams one over a hundred meters tall
will boost the country's annual
electricity generation
by up to 15 percent massive
absolutely massive isn't it well it's
going to be a big one
the turkish contractor says its
construction will only be positive
this project actually will provide
absolutely brand new
uh the high standard european student
road and the bridges
to connect with the kutaisi to taguiri
which will bring a lot of tourists a lot
of tourists
and also connect a lot of villages it's
a good opportunity to keep the
valley alive you can see the tunnel
there that's going to divert the river
that will allow them to build a massive
dam
across the gorge a feat of engineering
to tame this force of nature the rione
river
that will transform the valley for
better
or worse
downstream in georgia's second largest
city
kutaisi thousands recently protested
over fears the dams could unleash a
barrage of flood water
if there was an earthquake to address
public concerns georgia's government has
suspended the dam's construction for 12
months
hydropower plant is a strategically
important project for our
for our country i need to stress this
from there from
from the beginning um did the public
understand that
uh yes i think the part uh i think
majority of
the people understand that this is the
project we have to eventually
construct and implement but there are
some questions of course we understand
there are some concerns
and we need more communication
but the preparatory work continues
and police now control who enters the
valley
stop the work get the police out and
start a dialogue and in this dialogue
what questions we have and what answers
they give will decide whether the
project
should be built or not this hydropower
project
has sparked the biggest environmental
movement in georgia in years
but the government's determined to see
it finished
robin forrester walker al jazeera in the
rioni valley